bonjour à tous bienvenue sur les chaînes
parlementaires seller de parlement hebdo
avec aude moracchini bonjourbonjour
michael bonjour à tous et dans
l'actualité cette semaine ça ne va pas
vous surprendre a bien sûr parlé du
mariage pour tous deuxième semaine de
débats l'assemblée nationale les députés
y passe jour et nuit les débats traînent
en longueur quelques invectives mais
aussi un fou rire le vote est toujours
programmée pour la semaine prochaine
une véritable armée mexicaine on connaît
le nouvel organigramme de l'ump des vice
présidents comme s'il en pleuvait 20 au
total des copéistes des fillonistes il
leur faudra à tenir jusqu'au prochain
vote prévu en septembre
s'il a lieu ils sont quelques-uns
vouloir le repoussée après les élections
municipales
enfin nous parlerons d'un rapport
explosif de deux sénateurs pour ce label
les déserts médicaux
il ne croit pas aux mesures incitatives
de la ministre de la santé un suggère au
contraire de contraindre les médecins à
s'installer dans les zones où personne
ne veut aller quitte à jouer sur la
godasse est avec nous pour commenter
toute cette actualité de la semaine
laurent wauquiez bonjour merci d'être
avec nous et vous êtes député ump de
haute loire est l'un de ces fameux vice
président de l'ump alors vous avez été
nommé en janvier selon la bonne règle un
filloniste un copéiste vous en
fillonistes luc chate alors qu'au pays
c'est vous a été rejoint par une armée
dont deux vice présidents vous êtes 20
au total en un petit peu de mal à voir
quel est votre place est ce que vous
êtes
parmi les chefs des vice-présidents
est-ce que vous avez vous répartir c'est
quand vous allez faire je vais vous dire
d'abord la première chose c'est qu'on va
donner une image pitoyable
à la fin de l'année dernière et donc
même signe il ya un côté je suis lucide
un peu ridicule dans ces nominations
dans tous les sens avec des vice
présidents il en pleut des secrétaires
généraux il en pleut
des des responsabilités des instances de
décision y en a de partout j'ai vous
surprendre je préfère ça danse et vingt
vies secrètes je vais venir
je préfère l'armée mexicaine à la guerre
civile espagnole qu'on a connu à la fin
de l'année pour moi ça c'est clair que
ça va finir comme ça quand même
la guerre la guerre civile je ne cherche
pas à faire croire que tout d'un coup ça
s'est métamorphosée que tout le monde
que tout va bien pour le dans le
meilleur des mondes par magie je dis
juste en tout cas à mon niveau j'ai
décidé d'être résolument un facteur
d'apaisement et de rassemblement
voilà ni plus ni moins et je vais vous
en donner une réponse très simple
hier on était avec luc chatel tous les
deux à rouen pour lancer les états
généraux de l'opposition
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que nous
ce dont tu mens et c'est discuter des
postes
c'est discuté des petites places de
chacun de savoir vous êtes bien vice
président vous n'êtes pas bien de se
reconcentrer sur les sujets de fond par
exemple des sujets que vous avez pas
évoquer l'emploi n'a pas fini l'émission
commence on a discuté de petroplus
on va discuter de tout ça dans
l'émission deuxième volet pour continuer
à répondre à votre question les classes
moyennes quelle place des classes
moyennes a sommé par les impôts
aujourd'hui en france troisièmement
comment défendre nos emplois dans la
mondialisation le protectionnisme
européen
et oui moi je suis à l'aise dans ma
famille politique et dans mon parti dans
lequel je m'investis beaucoup quand on
débat de sujets de fond votre place
comme vice président à l'ump on a bien
compris
vous êtes également fondateur donc du
mouvement de la droite sociale on va y
revenir bien sûr mais auparavant c'est
la coutume on est allé demander à vos
amis et collègues députés aux quatre
colonnes ce qu'ils pensaient de vous et
c'est leur bouilhaguet qui a tendu sa
caméra laurent wauquiez est jeune
parlementaire est aussi un jeune homme
pour lequel j'ai amitié et même
affection parce qu'il a une fibre
sociale que moi le le gaulliste
j'apprécie beaucoup
je trouve que sur le mariage pour tous
il a défendu des positions qui me
semblent excessives par rapport à je
pense son réel positionnement politique
c'est quelqu'un pour qui j'ai du respect
et dont je salue l'intelligence
je ne le connais pas je trouve que
on connaît ces jeunes et cons
on défend des idées aussi aussi vieille
ça me surprend toujours un peu trop sur
la toile je le connais pas il aime prime
pas il est tellement intelligent que
parfois il va trop vite et qu'il n'est
pas compris par les autres
c'est un grave défaut donc il faut
qu'ils prennent le temps d'expliquer
mais c'est une très belle mécanique
intellectuelle
je comprends bien parce que dit jacobs
je comprends mieux ce que dit maritaux
banquier j'ai plus de mal c'est un un
élu responsable national qui est promis
au plus bel avenir politique dans notre
pays
c'est un garçon qui est très travailleur
très
très engagé très actif en particulier en
ce moment j'ai l'impression qu'il est en
train de se mobiliser dans la
perspective de la présidence de l'ump
mais je me trompe peut-être j'en ai pas
parlé récemment
alors contrairement à ce que dit patrick
mennucci ou essayer de comprendre ce que
vous dites pendant 45 minutes en même
temps je vais être très clair avec vous
mon objectif n'est pas de me faire
comprendre par patrick mennucci photo
par les français est aussi la dernière
appréciation de nathalie kosciusko
morizet actif dans la perspective de la
présidence de l'ump
elle se trompe je vais vous dire sur
tout et je vais revenir sur ce qu'on a
dit précédemment
j'ai très mal vécu la fin de l'année la
politique c'est le meilleur et le pire à
la fois le pire c'est les petites
batailles politiciennes et les querelles
d'ego ça existe y'a pas de naïveté avoir
ça fait partie de notre travail
le meilleur c'est les débats d'idées les
propositions la volonté de faire avancer
les choses concrètement à la fin de
l'année 2012
il n'y avait que le pire est donc moi ce
que je me suis juré c'est qu'au début de
l'année 2013 je voulais redonner une
voix l'opposition différentes
peut-être avec ce qu'est ma génération
mon approche des choses
une voix aussi qui assume ses
convictions et j'ai beaucoup souri en
écoutant les députés écologistes dans
mon obsession c'est pas d'être moderne
je ne suis pas là pour me dire voilà
faut être dans le sens de l'histoire
je suis là pour me demander est ce que
ce qu'on met sur la table c'est bon pour
les français ou c'est mauvais mais ne
répond pas leur bouquet wilno vous êtes
candidat
bon je vais répondre très clairement je
trouve cette question absurde
aujourd'hui vous preniez pas qu'on a
suffisamment donné dans le registre là
il ya deux trois mois donc ce donc j'ai
dû réfléchir
voilà bah je vous répond franchement
pour l'instant je pense qu'on doit tous
imposé une cure de désintoxication à
quelque chose comme angers se trompe et
l'a fait une réflexion absurde
non pas du tout c'est parce que je veux
dire matelly l ami avec un point
d'interrogation natal yele dans d'autres
perspectives qui sont les municipales de
paris
donc c'est normal qu'elle est en ce
moment ce type de réflexion et c'est
vraiment nos talons bras je la
soutiendrai sur paris mais mon sujet il
n'est pas là mon sujet pour moi en ce
moment il ya beaucoup de choses qu'on a
laissé passer et laisser faire par le
gouvernement il faut que l'opposition
montrent qu'elle est crédible et qu'elle
a des propositions en face c'est ça ce
que je veux faire alors on va attaquer
tout de suite le reste de l'actualité le
révoquer et bien sûr on commence par ce
marathon le bail
pour tous deuxième semaine de deux
débats à l'assemblée nationale lors
invoquer vous y avez participé notamment
comme vous allez le voir dans ce sujet
eh bien les polémiques prennent un petit
peu plus le pack sur le fond du texte
exemple dans la nuit de mercredi à jeudi
avec jérémie hoffmann
ce n'était pas un jour sans fin mais une
nuit sans fin hier soir dans l'hémicycle
une fois de plus la séance a commencé
par une montagne d'amendements de la
droite ou l'art de faire durer le
plaisir
l'article 375 8 dont il est question
pour avoir cité têtu je citais donc
marianne massacrer un texte c'est pas
très grave massacre et des enfants oui
ça c'est grave
une litanie de questions et d'invectivés
sans réponse de la majorité
pressé d'en finir la gauche décide de
jouer au roi du silence
résultat l'opposition se sent bien seul
pour débattre je cherche un
interlocuteur
je cherche quelqu'un avec qui débattre
pour la majorité difficile de tenir sa
langue
l'envy de riposter parfois trop forte je
lave ou à notre assemblée
je craque chaque collègue de
l'opposition vous avez été posée trop
d'amendements et vous ne savez plus
comment les défendre donne nous ton bon
maintenant dans le mauvais théâtre de
boulevard monsieur le furent des
échanges savoureux mais un débat qui
stagne rien que du déjà vu ces derniers
jours et ces dernières nuits jusqu'à
cette violente altercation
le patron des députés ump prend à parti
la présidente socialiste de la séance
j'ai demandé une suspension de séance
madame
vous attention perchoir ça vous oblige à
un certain nombre de choses ça vous
oblige à exercer une pression japon sial
le vent de la révolte souffle dans
l'hémicycle et c'est un écologiste qui
vole au secours de sa collègue
socialiste
vous avez mis en cause la présidence de
séance
malheureusement ce n'est pas la première
fois j'ai envie de dire d'ailleurs la
présidente car j'ai comme l'impression
que le fait que ce soit une présidente
n'est pas totalement étranger au mépris
avec lequel vous l'avez traité
c'est dans ce climat de fatigue et de
lassitude que s'est poursuivi l'examen
de l'article 4 du projet de loi
un article toujours pas voté à quatre
heures du matin l'heure où les députés
sont allés se coucher
laurent wauquiez on le voit le fonds est
un petit peu oublié c'est souvent les
polémiques et je vous ai vu même
intrigué par l'intervention de christian
jacob qui prennent le pas je vais vous
dire mon sentiment profond
j'écris un livre sur ce sujet qui
s'appelle un huron à l'assemblée
nationale jean jacques urvoas
voilà ce qu'on est en train de récolter
c'est quoi on est en train de récolter
les résultats d'un fonctionnement
absurde de l'assemblée nationale que le
gouvernement ait choisi une posture dans
laquelle il ne répond pas aux questions
que le président de l'assemblée
nationale est choisi en lien avec les
différents responsables
un système dans lequel on débâche qu'à
2h du matin y compris le week-end
non-stop
tout ceci est ridicule utiliser le temps
programmé
évidemment ce qu'il faut faire c'est
quoi c'est qu'il faut revoir totalement
nos modes de fonctionnement dans lequel
à l'avant sont dit voilà on débattra du
lundi 9 heures jusqu'au vendredi 22
heures du texte l'opposition aura-t-elle
temps de parole et vous pouvez organiser
comme vous voulez la majorité aura
t'elle temps de parole et vous pouvez
organiser comme vous voulez le
gouvernement sera obligé de répondre
c'est scandaleux de voir la garde des
sceaux qui ne répond à rien elle ne
donne pas sa position sur la gestation
pour autrui c'est pas un petit sujet sur
la prochaine loi
oui c'est pas dans le projet de loi ça
veut dire on nous le vend à la découpe
on fait passer le procès doit par petits
morceaux et donc nos regardez par vous
que bose est sacré chamion de saison
crazy qu'on veut pas voir ça deviendra
plus tard prophétie famille la maman qui
n'ont pas tout le temps rapport avec le
texte non plus non on dépose c'est vrai
des amendements pourquoi parce que un
fonctionnement absurde génère des
comportements absurdes ils voient gossio
à gauche aussi regarder la gauche
maintenant ils sont condamnés au silence
on leur a dit vous n'avez plus droit de
vous exprimer donc si on est obligé
d'aller sur twitter certains même sont
obligés ils disent ils craquent là on a
vu je crains parce que j'ai besoin de
parler mais où on est ce qui me gêne
beaucoup
c'est que ce débat doit être pour nous
tous la cote d' alerte d'un
fonctionnement du parlement qui n'est
plus moderne qui ne correspond plus aux
attentes d'un débat digne et sur des
sujets comme celui là il faut se poser
les bonnes questions et fait un peu de
responsabilité des députés ump ont
déposé un amendement est de la
responsabilité des députés ps vous y
voyez pas un peu de responsabilité du
gouvernement
je pense que ce que j'y vois c'est
d'abord le symptôme d'une assemblée qui
doit changer son mode de fonctionnement
et saas est urgent et je voudrais aussi
vous poser une question à vous il ya un
point qui moi me surprend ça fait dix
jours qu'on débatte ce texte est déjà on
a l'impression que les journalistes
trouvent que c'est trop long dix jours
passés trop les hommes politiques aussi
oui il y croit mais ces critiques le 4
c'est peut-être un petit peu long trois
jours sur un article qui change un code
civil qui vient de napoléon c'est trop
trois jours pour discuter de ce qu'est
la conception des parents dans la
société française c'est rond trois jours
pour prendre un tout petit peu de
réflexion pour se demander c'est quoi
notre conception de la famille c'est
trop donc il ya un moment aussi où il
faut qu'on fasse attention cette société
dans laquelle on est tous un les
politiques les médias
tout ça dans lequel on est dans une
espèce de précipitation ou discuté
pendant dix jours d'un sujet aussi
majeur que la place des enfants que les
bébés éprouvettes que la location du
ventre d'une femme on considère que
c'est trop là moi je considère pas que
c'est trop et là encore j'assume mes
convictions
on m'a expliqué que quand on avait 37
ans à l'aide pour etc
moi j'assume mes valeurs et mes
convictions et je suis frappé ainsi
rendu
marianne comprend le mariage pour tous
et je mets des fêtes députés ump
d'ailleurs oui c'est vrai parce que et
c'est sans doute mon approche aussi de
la politique je considère que quand on
fait de la politique on a des
convictions et on les assume
il faut pas les cacher elle ne figure
pas dans le projet de loi mais on en
parle beaucoup la procréation
médicalement assistée la pma elle devait
entrer dans un projet de loi sur la
famille en mars dominique bertinotti la
ministre l'avait certifier une nouvelle
fois en début de semaine et puis voilà
que jean marc ayrault contredit sa
ministre retour sur un cafouillage avec
valérie brochard dimanche matin les
députés communistes et écologistes munis
de leurs amendements relance le débat
sur la pma dans l'hémicycle la ministre
déléguée à la famille répond je
souhaiterais que monsieur le ministre
chargé des relations avec le parlement
ou madame bertinotti nous donne à la
fois la méthode le calendrier le
périmètre
et si oui ou non la pma figurera dans le
dans le projet de loi famille
la question de la procréation
médicalement assistée ouverte aux
couples de même sexe sera abordée dans
le cadre de cette loi famille
les députés socialistes avaient obtenu
la garantie de l'introduction de la pma
dans un texte sur la famille déposé le
27 mars prochain en conseil des
ministres il n'en fallait pas plus pour
que jean marc ayrault en voyage à phnom
penh interviennent pour recadrer la
ministre elle ne peut pas dire ça dans
la mesure
elle ne connaît pas la date de réponse
du comité national d'éthique donc si
c'était avant oui mais si c'est pas le
cas
il faut donc attendre l'avis du comité
consultatif national d'éthique
vraisemblablement seulement à l'automne
le calendrier de la réforme dépend
désormais de cet avis alors face aux
contradictions entre matignon et la
ministre les députés ump jubile que le
gouvernement clarifie sa position
est ce que oui ou non il attend l'avis
d'une commission nationale d'éthique ou
est ce qu il est prêt à inscrire ce
texte à l'ordre du jour
en s'asseyant sur la ville du comité
national d'éthique
même incertitude chez les défenseurs de
la paix m ce matin en me rassure au mode
il on va voter contre
votre amendement madame buffet mais vous
inquiétez pas ça dans la loi famille et
moi j'arrive ici leur propre premier
ministre dit sera pas dans la famille
pour qu'ils changent pas ce qu'est ce
que c'est fait parole ministériel qui
est démenti que fera le gouvernement si
l'avis du comité d'éthique est négatif
la pma sera telle inscrite dans un
projet de loi à l'automne prochain
pas sûr que le gouvernement est
aujourd'hui la réponse non sans beaucoup
d'atermoiements beaucoup d'embarras du
côté du gouvernement vous considérer ça
comme une victoire pour vous non moi je
considère jamais comme une victoire un
embarras du gouvernement
je trouve que là on est dans un grand
désordre on est dans un grand désordre
sur le fonctionnement du gouvernement
enfin voila quand même une ministre qui
dit quelque chose un premier ministre
qui depuis le cambodge
on appréciera deal inverse est
maintenant à la porte parole du
gouvernement qui dînent troisième chose
donc on est dans un grand désordre et ce
qui me gêne c'est précisément le
sentiment que sur ce débat le
gouvernement pour des arrière-pensées
politiques très clair veut passer en
force a choisi de ne pas prendre le
temps et a choisi d'imposer un débat il
passe pas en force on en reparlera on
verra s'il ya ou non avec sa création
médicalement assistée sera bien le
projet je suis convaincu que dans leur
vision de société
il y à la procréation médicalement
assistée et je voudrais rajouter un
dernier point et les français qui ont
exprimé leur inquiétude
les français sont majoritairement pour
le mariage pour les couples homosexuels
personnellement je suis favorable à une
union civile pour les couples
homosexuels et je suis favorable à ce
qu'on renforce les droits des
homosexuels dans la société française
mais mon point de différence c'est sur
la place des enfants
hélas ce qui me ce qui me gêne c'est que
ces inquiétudes elles n'ont pas été
entendues
et on le voit bien avec ce débat sur la
procréation médicalement assistée
on a le gouvernement qui débat entre lui
mais il n'écoute pas les français
alors pendant que les députés hall qui
examine le texte est bien les sénateurs
eux commencent les éditions notamment
dans un climat beaucoup plus serein sans
se précipiter des sociologues des
philosophes qui viennent tour à tour
prendre la parole compte rendu avec
nathalie war au sénat loin des objectifs
du palais bourbon le temps des auditions
a commencé une première journée marquée
par la présence d'éminents spécialistes
visiblement satisfait d'avoir pu
développer leur propos de la commission
du sénat m'a accordé comme aux autres je
suppose une heure alors que dans mon
souvenir quand j'ai été reçu à la
commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale nous étions cinq pour une
oeuvre
donc on avait un temps extrêmement
limité il n'y a pas de redites entre
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
parce que nous pouvons approfondir des
questions qui ne l'ont pas été et dont
on aperçoit au fur et à mesure de la
discussion qu au fond ces malentendus
sont au centre don et je crois que senna
va avoir un rôle très particulier dans
la capacité qu'il aura à démêler cette
caisse et malentendus sur la filiation
pour le rapporteur du texte sur le
mariage pour tous le débat n'en sera que
plus serein mais on verra quand le
violent quand le débat viendra en fait
je pense que ce sera beaucoup plus
apaisé au sénat et si j'en crois les
auditions conduites après midi on peut
voir que le climat était quand même plus
apaisée je sais par le rapporteur erwann
binet qui me l'avait dit que sa
déposition l'armée nationale avec les
prix houleuse ici ce n'est pas le cas
donc je crois qu'on aura un débat plus
serein plus apaisée et peut-être plus
constructif
les auditions au sénat ne font que
commencer durant trois semaines
associations de familles sociologues
philosophes et représentations des
cultes vont se succéder en commission
avant l'ouverture des débats
bon alors vous le voyez au sénat le
climat est complètement différent plus
apaisé on va dire est ce que c'est parce
qu'ils ont plus l'expérience du débat à
l'assemblée nationale
non je pense moi aussi une institution
que j'aime bien ces normes parce qu'elle
a un certain recul sur les choses et je
crois que c'est d'ailleurs l'utilité du
bicamérisme pour autant
soyons prudents je ne suis pas sûr que
foncièrement l'organisation du sénat
aboutir à un débat qui sera foncièrement
différent et puis un sujet qui elle a
aussi posé le rapporteur de la loi au
sénat
sauf erreur de ma part est favorable à
la gestation pour autrui la gestation
pour autrui je veux bien que chacun
comprenne selon il s'agit vous louez le
ventre d'une femme elle est rémunérée
le mât sénateurs ump qui est pour oui
mais pour moi c'est un sujet qui dépasse
les clivages gauche droite elle est
rémunérée
elle fait un enfant quand l'enfant né on
lui enlève sept enfants et ensuite il
est donné à d'autres
voilà est-ce que ça c'est le modèle de
société qu'on veut une fois de plus ça
n'est pas dans le projet de loi oui mais
une fois de plus ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que le rapporteur de
la loi lui même indiqué qu'il était pour
et que c'était le prolongement ce que je
trouve extraordinaire dans cette
approche
vous croyez que résonnent comme ça et
vous croyez que j'ai le regard rivé dans
le drogo non il est évident pour moi que
je me pose la question sur on ouvre une
porte elle nous amène jusqu où je vais
pas juste voté un petit texte de loi on
dira non mais il y en a un autre qui va
venir mais réfléchissez pas par rapport
à l'autre qui va venir
non ce que j'essaye de comprendre c'est
le procès de société d'ensemble du
gouvernement est ce que je reproche au
gouvernement c'est de nous faire décidé
que sur une toute petite partie est de
ne pas assumer ce qu'il veut faire sur
l'ensemble de son travail
alors on va revenir à l'assemblée une
nuit blanche dans la semaine des séances
qui s'achève au milieu de la nuit des
débats qui s'éternisent la fatigue
évidemment fait son apparition et avec
elle cette semaine un fou rire celui de
la ministre qui monte au créneau toute
la semaine évidemment christiane taubira
on regarde je suis persuadé vous
partagez avec nous le souci que le texte
soit bien écrit or si nous adoptons des
amendements comme ça nous écrivons mal
un texte de loi
c'est quand même la réalité par ailleurs
monsieur gosselin puisque c'est par
petits bouts que vous êtes
ouais et personnel je vais essayer de
vous répondre
papus par petits bouts bon j'en elle
invente regard jeu j'ai un élan
bon elle un petit moment de détente très
bien qu'on repasse quand même ça fait le
tour de la toile
au-delà de ça christiane taubira dans
l'hémicycle vous la trouvez comment elle
a gagné cinq points dans les sondages
christiane taubira moi j'ai du respect
pour elle c'est quelqu'un qui assume ses
convictions elle le fait avec un certain
enthousiasme dans ce projet de loi mais
il ya un petit problème qui me gêne
c'est qu'elle est garde des sceaux et
qui est un autre volant de son action
théorique c'est de s'assurer que la
justice fonctionne bien et de s'assurer
que des gens qui sont jugés et bien en
prison
est ce que j'aimerais c'est que
l'énergie qu'elle met sur ce projet de
loi
elles investissent de la même manière
sur la gestion de la politique de
sécurité
or on l'a vu là bas c'est clairement pas
le cas pourquoi les discours qu'elle
tient sur la prison les discours qu'elle
tient qui sont des vrais discours de
laxisme par rapport à la gestion et
l'exécution de gens qui ont été
condamnés aboutissent aux sentiments qui
a été clairement exprimée des policiers
et des gendarmes de ne pas être suivis
et épauler dans leur travail
la situation de l'as et de l'insécurité
est en train de se dégrader très vite et
ils ont très clairement dit qu'il
n'était pas soutenu par la justice ce
qui me permet d'ouvrir un autre thème on
débat beaucoup en ce moment du mariage
et de l'adoption là beaucoup fait sur
votre plateau mais quand on débatte sans
débat pas du reste et l'énergie que
madame taubira mais sur ce sujet
visiblement elle ne le met pas sur les
autres thématiques de gestion de la
justice et de l'insécurité et il serait
bon que ce débat se termine finalement
ce que j'ai envie de dire c'est qu'on
allait christiane taubira
mais à tout le monde d'être à tout le
monde encore encore une fois je fais
juste aller jusqu'au bout on a donc une
christiane taubira qui est pour moi de
visage un visage qui est celle qui met
beaucoup d'énergie sur le mariage et
l'adoption est un autre visage qui met
peu d'énergie détermination sur la
gestion des peines de prison et
l'exécution des décisions de justice
allez on va s'arrêter là sur ce volet du
mariage pour tous on va dérouler la
semaine mardi tient françois fillon est
au siège de l'ump
françois fillon n'avait pas remis les
pieds rue de vaugirard au siège de l'ump
depuis un certain 18 novembre où ils
étaient venus contester la victoire de
son rival ce mardi matin un comité
politique réuni les deux hommes et leurs
équipes tonalité de la rencontre on se
retrousse les manches et on essaie
d'oublier les querelles l'ump a traversé
des moments très difficiles
je n'oublie rien du passé mais il est
temps aujourd'hui nous mettre au travail
à la fois parce que le pays a besoin
d'entendre la voix de l'opposition et
puis parce que nous avons trouvé les
moyens de réfléchir à des réformes de
l'organisation de notre mouvement des
procédures pour les élections qui
permettent je l'espère d'éviter de se
retrouver dans la situation dramatique
que nous avons connue je crois que
vraiment la page est tournée et que la
priorité absolue maintenant pour nous
c'est de nous occuper des préoccupations
des français
alors vous étiez on sent pas un
enthousiasmant là on sent que fillon dit
qu'il nous françois fillon dit qu'il
n'oublie rien françois copé
jean-françois copé bon veut tourner la
page
on n'a pas senti un enthousiasme
délirant ce mardi matin
vous savez moi je suis pas favorable à
raconter des gargouilles est en
politique il ya eu des blessures et des
failles
ça a été difficile tout ça ça se
cicatrisent pas par magie et il faut pas
faire semblant de dire voilà maintenant
tout va bien et tout le monde s'embrasse
sur la bouche ce serait ridicule
par contre et ça je le répète moi je
suis déterminé à jouer ce rôle d'un
travail en équipe
pas vraiment de nouvelles élections on
entend beaucoup de députés ump notamment
qui se demande si ça vaut vraiment la
peine d'y retourner de refaire peut-être
un psychodrame à la rentrée prochaine
voilà réponse est dans votre question
comment est ce que vous vous les lavez
ce qui s'est passé si on donne le
sentiment que l'ump est incapable
d'organiser une élection transparente et
démocratique
l'élection qui s'est déroulée a été
entaché d'irrégularités très forte on
est un parti démocratique ne pas être
capable d'organiser une élection
transparente c'est quand même grave
et donc si après ce qui s'est passé avec
des irrégularités ont dû boire
maintenant en plus on va gentiment
laissé stocker la poussière à l'inter de
la maison élections pour prouver qu'on
sait faire des élections une élection
pour laver ce qui s'est passé c'est la
première chose
la deuxième chose est au fond toutes vos
questions de souligner on voit bien qu
aulas qui est en train de se passer
permet de travailler sur une phase
transitoire ensemble et si on veut
donner des fondations saines
il faut une élection qui permettent de
désigner une équipe resserrée avec un
vrai organiser une vraie organisation de
travail est quelque chose qui soit un
peu claires parce que là c'est quand
même assez lourds
donc c'est bien pour panser les
blessures c'est bien sûr une phase
transitoire mais si on veut donner des
fondations saines à notre parti il ya
besoin moment d'une élection alors
qu'est ce que vous pensez de jean
françois copé qui veut recruter pour les
municipales via des petites annonces
vous vice-président qu'est ce que vous
en pensez d'abord un vrai sujet
le vrai sujet c'est d'arriver à
mobiliser les gens pour s'investir
localement dans leur commune c'est un
vrai sujet
2 la proposition donc je comprends que
le de ce point de vue jean françois copé
essaye d'attirer et de trouver des
nouveaux élus qu'il le propose par des
voix on va dire créative un peu étrange
ça a le mérite d'être créatif - mon
sentiment c'est lequel c'est que c'est
pas ça qu'il faut privilégier ce qu'on
doit privilégier ses les talents notre
parti ce qu'on doit privilégier ses des
militants qui s'investissent dans la vie
quotidienne de notre parti il y en a
beaucoup de talent on a beaucoup de
jeunes des jeunes adhérents des jeunes
militants des jeunes populaires qui
croient à la politique qui se sont
investis donner de son temps d'accord
avec la proposition de jean-françois
copé
non c'est parce que je voudrais dire
mais des militants qui s'investissent
dans un parti c'est assez extraordinaire
c'est des gens qui donnent faim qui
donnent de leur temps pour les autres
qui attendent pas forcément retour qu'on
leur permette aussi d'exercer des
responsabilités qu'on leur fasse
confiance
je trouve ça bien donc on a une
génération nouvelle affaire montée
essayons aussi de leur faire confiance
en intérieur génération nouvelle vous
avez réuni cette semaine les militants
qui ont signé votre motion la droite
sociale ils ont été réunis au palais des
congrès à paris nous avons interrogé ses
militants pour savoir ce qu'il pensait
en ce moment deux sets
guerre post guerre à l'ump et après vous
êtes hors jeu sur la droite sociale ce
qu'est exactement à droite sociale
écouter pour nous il était important
mais enfin secondaires et de toute façon
il ya suffisamment de personnalité nous
savons très bien pour qu'ils nous allons
voter mais nous ne sommes pas inquiets
il ya une équipe qui est mis en place
donc elle va travailler justement pour
pour préparer les futures élections et
je pense que c'est important de
travailler dans la sérénité
surtout aujourd'hui avec tout le débat
les débats parlementaires où il faut
être fort et puis semble plutôt apprécié
des militants mais vous ne croyez pas au
ras-le-bol à terme mais tout ça je crois
surtout que ce que les militants vol
c'est qu'on fasse que je vous disais
cette phase de désintoxication où tout
le monde se calme on fait un peu baisser
la pression
on retravaille sur le fond après on fait
une élection sereine où on montre notre
capacité à redonner des bonnes
fondations à la maison de l'ump et
ensuite on repart sur notre travail
d'opposition et de proposition et ça
c'est ce qui m'intéresse c'est la droite
sociale jours a commandé un petit mot
quand même est ce que pour vous la
droite sociale c'est l'anti gauche
est ce que tout ce qui est fait
aujourd'hui par la goule disent qu'il
faut du social est bon à jeter
d'abord la première source de la droite
sociale c'est un travail en équipe c'est
des parlementaires et des élus de
terrain et c'est pas que des discours
sert ce sont des gens qui expérimentent
chez eux dans leur commune dans leur
département des propositions je vais
donner des exemples on a un programme
pour essayer de financer des permis de
conduire pour des jeunes avec en
contrepartie pendant l'été les jeunes
qui s'engagent pour s'investir dans une
association les maisons de retraite la
caserne des pompiers
un équilibre de droits et de devoirs le
travail de la droite sociale c'est la
lutte contre l'assistanat est par
exemple dans mon centre d'action sociale
les gens qu'on aime on leur demande
systématiquement contrepartie aussi
donner un peu de leur temps pour la
collectivité
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
oui c'est essayer de sortir d'un
politiquement correct quand vous disiez
vue coupe et je vous attends deux bouts
quand vous disiez l'assistanat c'est le
cancer de la société
ça c'est jack c'est ça qu'il faut ce
sont des phrases comme cela alors je
vais aller jusqu'au bout de ce que je
pense ce que je pense d'abord c'est
qu'il ya beaucoup trop de politiques en
france aujourd'hui qui ne
disent plus rien qu'ils sont enfermés
dans un politiquement correct drapé dans
des bons principes qui sont totalement
des connexions avec la réalité de ce que
ressentent et les interrogations se
posent les français aujourd'hui
l'interrogation des français aujourd'hui
c'est les retraités a sommé de charges
et d'impôts qui n'arrivent pas à s'en
sortir et auquel jean marc ayrault
expliquent qu'ils font partie des
privilégiés ou de ceux qui sont à l'aise
les incompréhensions aujourd'hui c'est
le salarié au smic qui part avec sa
voiture pour aller travailler à 20
kilomètres de chez lui et qui n'arrivent
plus à amortir sa voiture qu'il peut
plus payer les pneus neige et qu'il a
toute une partie de son salaire dans
plein d'essence
les interrogations des français
aujourd'hui c'est les familles qui ont
du mal à financer les études de leurs
enfants quand elles sont je suis pas une
pose des problèmes mais on ne donne pas
les solutions
c'est pour ça mais vous avez suivi nos
travaux que la droite sociale mais à
chaque fois des propositions on prend un
exemple sur l'essence pour nous à vous
pouvez pas me reprocher de pas
d'opposition propose un chèque carburant
sur le modèle de ce qui existe sur le
ticket restaurant ce pays est
extraordinaire on aime les français
acheté un ticket restaurant les aide pas
à mettre le plein d'essence qui leur
permet d'aller travailler
un système dans lequel il est financé en
partie par les entreprises et les
organismes professionnels financé en
partie par la personne lui même individu
lui même et ça nous permettrait de
financer l'équivalent d'un plein
d'essence par mois
pourquoi le gouvernement ne fait pas ça
il avait premier blocage du prix de
l'essence
ils l'ont pas fait qu'est ce qu'ils
attendent pour avancer sur ce sujet on
va continuer si vous voulez bien ce
mardi toujours françois hollande est à
strasbourg devant les députés européens
il est invité à s'exprimer sur sa vision
de l'europe et surtout sur le budget qui
va être négocié en fin de semaine
exercice inhabituel
les parlementaires européens peuvent
l'interpeller dans l'hémicycle
évidemment daniel cohn bendit ne s'en
est pas privé jean baptiste daoulas
étaient sur place
sa position sur le budget étaient
attendus devant les députés françois
hollande dégaine une formule choc faire
des économies oui affaiblir l'économie
non un compromis est possible mais il
doit être raisonnable et donc
il va falloir raisonnée ceux qui veulent
amputer le budget européen
au delà de ce qu'il est possible
d'accepter lutte contre l'austérité
diminution des rabais et d'échec le
budget voulue par la france est presque
trop beau pour daniel cohn-bendit
françois jetté compris le changement
c'est maintenant
alors allons-y tout droit chiche et
banco plus inattendu le soutien de
certains députés du ppe ancré à droite
eux non plus ne veulent pas entendre
parler du projet de baisse du budget la
proposition actuelle c'est un
renoncement politique et je voulais dit
tout de suite nous allons le rejeter
monsieur le président mais ce
volontarisme affiché par françois
hollande laisse de marbre
un autre député du pp on est à la limite
du double jeu devant le parlement
le présent la république dit ah les mots
que le parlement envie d'entendre
mais en pratique il est résigné à ce que
le budget européen diminue un double
langage de françois hollande c'est aussi
ce que pense un de ses anciens camarades
d'un air très grave il dit nous ne
permettrons pas à qu'on réduit jeudi le
budget au delà de ce qui est supportable
alors vous ne saurez pas pourquoi il
faut réduire le budget européen ce qui
est une bêtise absolue ni qu'est ce
qu'il appelle supportable et à la fin il
termine en disant nous allons faire ma
responsabilité de faire un compromis
voilà on a baissé dit vos crises aligné
un point bas après son opération
séduction face aux députés aujourd'hui
françois hollande aura un public
beaucoup moins réceptif
lors du conseil européen jeudi alors on
a vu effectivement lors du conseil
européen comme il est difficile de se
mettre d'accord
l'ancien mise à faire européenne que
vous êtes a sans doute suivi cette
prestation avec intérêts ils se
débrouillent bien françois hollande pour
défendre une part quand même de relance
de croissance dans cette europe en crise
d'abord l'opposition c'est pas de faire
un travail qui soit stupide la france a
besoin d'avoir un soutien global sur ses
positions
notre intérêt est qu'un certain nombre
de sujets au sein du budget européen
soit défendu le budget de la recherche
parce que c'est les emplois de demain
erasmus parce que ça aide nos étudiants
et puis le budget de la politique
agricole commune dont les français ne
doivent jamais oublier qu'elle
conditionne aussi la force de notre
industrie agroalimentaire et donc de
très nombreux emplois
- sur ces dossiers s'ils sont défendus
par le président de la république je le
soutiens sur la scène européenne
parce qu'il faut pas qu'on soit stupide
mais attention je ne veux pas qu'on soit
trompé il ya une position qui a été
énoncé défense du budget européen tel
qu'il est pas de baisse du budget
européen sur cette position là je
soutiens mais je ne veux pas être
trompée ensuite comme la tâche est
difficile
oui françois hollande sur cette caisse
est attention quand on dit quelque chose
faut le tenir
j'ai la scène de bruxelles comme chez
nous on va passer au mercredi il y
aurait encore de l'espoir pour l' usine
petroplus en ce mercredi le personnel de
petroplus et rassemblés devant le site
de la raffinerie de rouen 450 salariés
qu'ils vont passer de l'espoir à la
désillusion
cinq offres de reprise ont été déposées
mais dans l'après midi la direction
les administrateurs judiciaires annonce
le rejet estimant qu'elles ne sont pas
assez structuré
au final c'est le tribunal de commerce
qui tranchera arnaud montebourg affirme
qu'il croit en qui croient encore et au
sénat il annonce même qu'il soutient les
propositions de reprise égyptienne et
suisse et qu'il a l'appui du premier
ministre on écoute le gouvernement a
décidé de s'engager derrière une offre
et une deuxième intéressante de manière
à obtenir la reprise c'est raffinerie
c'est une stratégie industrielle nous
avons des besoins
nous devons nous-mêmes défendre ses
capacités là donc si nous trouvons un
investisseur comme certains se sont
présentés hier
eh bien nous nous en réjouissons donc à
nous de faire tenir debout cette offre
est le premier ministre a dit qu' il
serait possible qu'il y ait une
participation minoritaire ou confirmés
dans le capital bien entendu de cet
investisseur s'ils le souhaitent
arnaud montebourg qui était au micro
d'un certain michael ray metz faut-il
sauver petroplus je vais vous dire
d'abord l'image elle parle d'elle-même
il ya des salariés qui sont sur le
terrain qui sont devant leur usine
auquel on a tenu des fausses promesses
et qui vont de promesses en désillusions
et de l'autre côté il ya un ministre du
redressement productif qui parle avec
les ors de la république dans le dos
bien confortablement assis sur son
palais et qui lui a raconté tout et
n'importe quoi vous faites une chronique
hebdomadaire vous l'auriez fait lundi le
même ministre aurait expliqué qu'il n'y
avait aucune offre
vous l'auriez fait mardi le même
ministre a expliqué qu'il y avait cinq
offres crédibles vous l'a fait en fin de
semaine il ya l'administrateur
judiciaire et le tribunal de commerce
qui a expliqué qu'il n'y avait en
réalité aucune offre qui était
suffisamment avancé et donc moi ce qui
me gêne c'est qu'on a un mini ce qui est
beaucoup dans les effets d'annoncé il
est bien sur les plateaux il explique
bien les choses le travail de fond je ne
le vois pas participation de l'état cite
ainsi un repreneur ce s'avérait sérieux
vous eeb le mental évoquées ci dessus
évoqués il le dit non pas lui dire de
montebourg lundi on serait prêt à
investir entre 15 et pas pour ça on a
pardonné tap
oui sauf que il nous on nous parlait de
nationalisation sur florence elle est où
la nationalisation la a visiblement d'un
petit peu reculer
bah oui vous l'avez berne l'a résumé le
directeur du terril avait bien résumé
directeur de l'abbaye de vous savez nous
dit on dirait bien résumé la situation
on a un ministre du redressement
productif qu elle nous raconte tout
quelconque et premiers ministres qui
veulent pas parler de nationalisation
c'est pas le ministre du redressement
productif
non mais c'est un gouvernement c'est par
un gouvernement qui décide vous savez
bien vous avez été au gouvernement aussi
mais alors c'est vous avez très bien
résumé les choses il y en a qui
dessinent et il ya les autres qui
racontent n'importe quoi
c'est ça le message qui est envoyé aux
salariés voilà un ministre qui annonce
qu on peut faire des nationalisations
ensuite finalement peu plus en faire il
dit qu'à une offre il ya plus d'offres
c'est quoi ce travail je les ai tarder
et à l'emploi vous même vous avez connu
cette désindustrialisation ses cent
vingt 120 mille emplois en trois ans
qu'on a qu'on a connus vous avez aussi
connu des difficultés dans les dents les
repreneurs explications difficile oui
mais vous voyez il est précisément je
voulais dit je suis allé discuter avec
des salariés qui étaient des salariés de
petroplus est notamment l'un d'entre eux
qui a suivi ce dossier de part en part
lui ce qu'il dit c'est qui ajuste un
désespoir qui s'installe parce qu'on
leur a raconté tout et n'importe quoi et
je vais aller jusqu'au bout de ce qu'ils
aiment à penser parce que la question
n'est pas que petroplus et sa renault
goodyear petroplus quel est le point
commun le gouvernement a assommé les
classes moyennes et les familles
modestes d'impôts assommés ya jamais eu
un tel choc fiscal dans ce pays 15
milliards d'euros qui sont tombées sur
le dos des français ils n'ont plus les
moyens d'acheter des automobiles les
immatriculations plonge - 12 % d
industrialisation vous serez d'accord ne
date pas de juin dernier
je vous donne un chiffre vous connaissez
la baisse du nombre de plaques
d'immatriculation il ya un effondrement
du marché de l'automobile en france la
consommation d'essence plonge la
consommation d'eau pneus plonge le
résultat c'est que le gouvernement est
en train de récolter ce qu'il a semé
c'est qu'il a tué la consommation par
une politique très violent de hausses
d'impôts par baisse des dépenses de
l'état hausses d'impôts c'est les
français auxquels il demande de purger
les déficits qui sont les déficits
publics
le résultat c'est qu'il ya plus de
consommation et que comme ya plus de
consommation nos industries plonge vers
les sujets si vous le voulez bien c'est
au jeudi celui des déserts médicaux
c'est un rapport explosif qui prend le
contre-pied de ce qu'a annoncé jusque là
la ministre de la santé pour lutter
conte ce covenant appelle les déserts
médicaux deux sénateurs proposent deux
mesures vous allez le voir radical
fabrice qu'une et avec ce rapport hervé
maurey et les sénateurs du groupe de
travail s'attaque à un tabou la liberté
d'installation des médecins mesures
chocs exclure de la sécurité sociale les
praticiens qui s'installerait en zone
surdotée un dispositif qui existe déjà
pour d'autres professions de santé comme
les kinés ou les infirmières ça existe
pour ces professions et ça fonctionne
bien
la preuve en est c'est que le nombre
d'infirmières dans les zones
sous-dotées a augmenté de 30% la suite
de la mise en place de cette mesure
donc dès lors que ça fonctionne pour les
infirmières je ne vois pas pourquoi on
ne tenterait pas de mettre ça en place
pour les médecins en décembre le
gouvernement a choisi une autre voie
un plan de 50 millions d'euros et 12
mesures mais des mesures incitatives
j'ai eu l'occasion de m'exprimer devant
cette mission est de dire que je ne
croyais pas aux mesures coercitives et
cal inverse il me semble nécessaire de
nous engager enfin dans une démarche
d'incitation forte parce que
contrairement à ce que l'on croit
la citation n'a jamais été tentée la
ministre le sait limiter la liberté
d'installation des médecins est très
impopulaire dans la profession a
commencé chez les étudiants comme ici à
paris 5
on a on a passé au minimum 6 ans des
tués de plus trois ans d'internât donc
ça fait ça au moins neuf ans si on veut
faire la médecine générale et après neuf
ans d'études si on se dit voilà on
pourra pas aller où on veut honnêtement
ça va ça va valoir un tollé côté je
pense
ironie de l'histoire politique jean marc
ayrault et marisol touraine voulait
soumettre l'installation des médecins à
un accord de l'administration
c'était en 2011 l'arrivée au
gouvernement a visiblement changé la
donne vous êtes maire du puy revenait
est ce que vous êtes touchés par exemple
par ce qu'on appelle les déserts
médicaux par selon le médecin finalement
qu'il ne vienne pas travailler va chez
un élu terrain la haute loire est un
département qui est très touchée par ces
problématiques de déserts médicaux
j'ai été amené encore récemment mba pour
arriver à installer une maison de santé
dans une commune de haute loire qui
avait du mal à pouvoir installer des
nouveaux médecins et on essaye de mettre
en place des partenariats chez nous
notamment dans les facultés de médecine
où on finance des bourses étudiantes
pour que en échange il puisse y avoir
des étudiants qui ensuite s'engagent à
venir exercer dans des déserts médicaux
je les fais quand j'étais ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur coercitives
comme le proposait sénateurs ça vous
semble
il ya peut-être un équilibre qu'on peut
trouver et peut-être pas aussi brutale
que de dire que l'on interdit la santé
mais au moins je crois beaucoup plus au
système est malheureusement la ministre
de la santé fait un plan qui est
totalement cosmétique et qui n'aura pas
d'impact moi je crois surtout à une
chose qui me semble beaucoup plus
intelligente
on paye les études des étudiants on les
aide sa peine
dd aussi des familles modestes parce que
payer des études de médecine c'est cher
et en échange il ya un engagement
s'engager pendant dix ans à exercer dans
des zones où on a besoin de médecins ça
c'est intelligent laurent wauquiez merci
d'avoir participé à cette émission
petite question très personnelle vous
l'avez toujours 7 par ko mauriste
éditorialistes tout le monde se posait
des questions et ont même prêt à lever
un fonds pour vous offrir une autre
verte chez elle et c'est vous savez on a
tous nos petits grigris c'est une veste
porte bonheur et qui m'a beaucoup aidé
notamment dans ma ville du puy et qui
m'a été offert par ma femme
merci d'avoir participé et nous on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine